Transcription: Heloise Marguier
Relecteur: eric vautier
179 millions de tonnes.
Voici la production mondiale
de poisson en 2018.
Ce chiffre ne vous parle pas ?
Eh bien, moi non plus, parce
qu’honnêtement, dans notre assiette,
il n’y en a qu’un de poisson,
alors on ne se sent pas vraiment concerné.
D'ailleurs, pensez à la dernière fois
que vous avez mangé du poisson.
C’était peut-être du cabillaud,
l’un des poissons préférés des Français.
Mais savez-vous à quoi ressemble
le cabillaud vivant ?
Dans cette société du tout accessible,
du multi-écrans,
nous pensons être hyperconnectés,
alors qu’en fait nous avons perdu le lien
avec le plus essentiel :
le lien avec l’océan.
Alors nous le détruisons.
Nous le polluons, nous le réchauffons,
nous le vidons, nous l’envahissons,
le puisons, nous urbanisons,
bref, dans cette ère de l’anthropocène
la planète bleue est en souffrance,
donc nous allons
être en souffrance avec elle.
Vous l'avez compris, Water is not coming.
Je m’appelle Alice Vitoux,
je suis surfeuse
et profondément, profondément
amoureuse de la biodiversité marine.
Je suis fascinée par ce monde invisible
et si peu connu,
de la plus majestueuse des baleines
au plus petit des planctons.
Je trouve incroyable que des espèces
aient réussi à s’adapter
pour vivre dans les grands fonds marins,
dans la quasi-obscurité,
avec si peu de nourriture
et tant de prédateurs.
Mais aujourd’hui, nous mettons en danger
ces espèces
alors que nous n’avons même pas
pris le temps de les connaître.
Face à ce constat,
j’ai décidé de changer d’employeur,
de travailler maintenant
pour quelqu’un qui me donne de l’émotion,
de l’espoir, de l’énergie :
l'Océan.
La feuille de route de mon job
est simple :
il faut que je vous donne envie d’agir
pour le préserver.
Mais comment faire
alors que vous habitez peut-être
à plusieurs centaines
de kilomètres de la mer ?
Je pourrais vous noyer sous les chiffres.
Beaucoup sont impressionnants
et malheureusement,
de nombreux sont alarmants.
Mais honnêtement, est-ce qu’un jour, un
chiffre vous a déjà donné envie d’agir ?
C’est l’océanographe François Serrano
qui le dit extrêmement bien :
tous les chiffres,
toutes les données scientifiques
ne remplaceront jamais,
jamais,
l’expérience de l’océan.
Il est urgent
de se reconnecter au vivant
pour le laisser
vous provoquer des émotions.
Alors, en 2019, j’ai décidé de créer
un atelier, la Fresque océane,
inspirée de la Fresque du climat.
C’est un atelier ludique et collaboratif.
Il n’y a qu’une seule règle du jeu : les
participants ont une centaine de cartes.
Chacune représente un élément de l'océan
ou des activités humaines.
Ils doivent alors retrouver les liens
entre toutes ces cartes
pour reconstruire une vision systémique
des enjeux
de la préservation de l’océan.
Ils vont se plonger
dans la biodiversité marine,
dans la pêche, les industries maritimes,
le climat, la pollution.
Ils vont comprendre, ils vont ressentir
et ils vont réfléchir ensemble
à des solutions, des actions.
Plusieurs milliers de participants
y ont déjà joué
et portent maintenant la voix
de l'océan.
Alors, pour que vous aussi vous puissiez
expérimenter cette reconnexion profonde,
je vous propose de partir avec moi
pour une petite plongée.
Le record du monde d’apnée
est de 11 minutes,
Alors je vous invite à tous prendre
une très grande respiration
et nous allons maintenant tous
mettre ensemble la tête sous l’eau.
L’océan est là, à nos pieds.
Il ne demande qu’à nous inspirer,
qu’à nous émerveiller.
Pourtant nous, nous cherchons plutôt
à explorer la Lune, à aller sur Mars.
Nous nous passionnons pour Star Wars,
pour Star Trek,
mais en réalité,
explorons plutôt Sea Wars ou Ocean Trek.
Parce qu'en fait, la plus incroyable
des étoiles, la voici.
Saviez-vous qu’elle est capable,
par sa toute petite bouche,
de sortir son estomac
pour digérer ses proies
à l’extérieur de son corps ?
Si vous êtes plutôt immortalité,
alors regardez la méduse :
elle est extrêmement résistante à la
pollution, au dérèglement climatique.
Dans certains endroits, on va même parler
de gélification des océans.
Et l’une de ces espèces est dite
immortelle, car à sa mort,
ses cellules se régénèrent
pour redevenir une méduse.
Si vous êtes plutôt super-pouvoirs,
alors ce sera plutôt la pieuvre pour vous.
Elle a huit bras, trois cœurs
et neuf cerveaux.
Elle est capable de changer de couleur,
de changer de forme,
et même de prendre l’apparence
d’autres animaux.
Pas mal, non ?
Tout va bien ?
Alors on continue et on
explore l’océan un peu plus profond.
L’océan est partout chez nous.
L’océan est à la base du cycle de l’eau.
C’est l’eau que l’on boit, l’eau qui sert
à faire pousser nos aliments.
L'eau qui sert à laver nos maisons,
nos cuisines, nos salles de bains.
L’eau qui permet de produire
nos vêtements,
nos voitures, nos téléphones.
L’océan est omniprésent
dans notre société.
Pourtant, nous ne le voyons même plus.
Et l’océan, ce n’est même pas
que de l’eau ou des poissons.
Regardez par exemple :
ici, vous voyez une ville ?
Moi, je vois l’Océan.
Car en fait, le sable que l’on utilise
pour construire nos maisons,
nos immeubles,
ce n’est pas du sable des déserts,
mais bien du sable des fonds marins.
Ici, vous voyez une station-service ?
L’océan à nouveau.
Car un tiers de notre production
de gaz et de pétrole
provient d’extractions offshore.
Ici, des médicaments, votre pharmacie ?
Vous l’avez compris, l’océan à nouveau.
Puisque la médecine s’inspire
des espèces marines,
du corail, des éponges, des invertébrés
ou bien des vers marins
pour oxygéner le sang
et favoriser les greffes ;
du poisson, pour faire
des pompes cardiaques
ou encore de l’étoile de mer, encore elle,
pour guérir de la mucoviscidose.
Inspirant, non ?
Alors si vous êtes toujours avec moi,
on continue notre petite plongée.
L’océan est partout chez nous.
Mais nous sommes aussi partout chez lui.
Si je vous dis que vous portez
en ce moment même sur vous
l’une des pires causes
de pollution des océans,
ça vous intrigue, non ?
Je parle des fibres synthétiques
de nos vêtements
qui sont relâchées par milliers
à chaque passage dans la machine à laver.
Très mal filtrées
par les stations d’épuration,
elles se retrouvent dans les cours d’eau
et donc dans les mers.
Et si je vous dis que vous avez peut-être,
la semaine dernière,
tué un requin ou bien une raie manta
ou une tortue luth ?
Eh bien, en fait, ces espèces sont prises
accidentellement par nos bateaux de pêche
pour pêcher nos poissons.
C’est ce qu’on appelle dans le jargon,
tristement, des prises accessoires.
Bien souvent morts,
ils sont ainsi rejetés par-dessus bord.
Et si je vous parle
d’absorption du carbone,
vous allez certainement penser
au fait de planter des arbres,
alors qu’en fait, les algues marines
et le phytoplancton
constituent une excellente
pompe à carbone.
L’océan est capable d’absorber
un quart de nos émissions de CO2
et plus de 90 % de l’énergie
qui est retenue sur Terre
à cause de nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre.
Mais il en paye le prix fort.
Il se réchauffe, il s’acidifie, se modifie
et donc les écosystèmes entiers
sont alors déséquilibrés.
Je vous invite maintenant
à reprendre votre souffle
et à revenir avec moi sur la terre ferme.
L’océan est partout.
C’est notre alimentation,
notre consommation, notre production,
c’est également nos moyens de transport,
nos matières premières.
L’océan est partout,
c’est un précieux régulateur du climat
et donc il est au cœur
des enjeux de ce siècle.
Pourtant, nous le mettons en danger.
Mais tout cela est peut-être
peu concret pour vous,
vous vous dites :
« Oui, mais moi, dans tout ça ? »
Eh bien, j’ai une très bonne nouvelle
pour vous.
En réalité, nous habitons tous
au bord de l’océan.
Oui, bon, d’accord,
peut-être pas cette maison-là,
mais quand on y pense,
notre maison, notre entreprise,
notre collectivité, notre école,
tout est relié à l’océan, de manière
directe ou indirecte.
Donc, en fait, chacun de nos gestes
a un impact positif ou négatif.
Alors, je sais que vous n’allez pas
dès demain vivre sans vêtements
pour arrêter de polluer l’océan
de nos fibres synthétiques.
Et je sais que l’humanité
ne deviendra pas végétarienne dès demain.
Mais quand on y réfléchit,
si à partir d’aujourd’hui, vous achetez
un maximum de vos vêtements
en seconde main plutôt que neuf,
ça fera donc moins
d’extraction de matières premières,
moins de transport, moins de pollution,
moins de consommation d’eau.
Et tout ça va contribuer
à la préservation de l’océan.
C’est donc déjà votre pouvoir
en un achat de vêtement.
Et si à partir de demain,
vous décidez de changer
votre consommation de poisson
en consommant moins, mais mieux aussi.
Ça veut dire privilégier
la pêche artisanale,
varier vos consommations de poisson,
ou bien tout simplement suivre
des guides de consommation.
Ainsi, vous limiterez la surpêche,
la destruction des habitats,
les prises accessoires.
Tout ça, c'est déjà votre pouvoir
dans votre assiette.
Mais la préservation de l’océan
ne passera bien sûr
pas que par des actions individuelles.
Ce sera aussi notre capacité
à pêcher durablement,
à légiférer sur la haute mer,
à faire du transport plus responsable,
à adopter une sobriété énergétique,
à créer de véritables
aires marines protégées
et bien sûr, à sensibiliser
toutes les générations.
Tout ça, c’est le pouvoir du collectif,
mais donc en fait,
comme le collectif, c’est nous,
c’est également notre pouvoir.
Pour que l’océan reste vivant
et en bonne santé,
et donc pour que nous aussi
nous restions vivants et en bonne santé.
Pour conclure,
j’aimerais vous demander
maintenant quelle est
la couleur de l’environnement ?
Avant, vous m’auriez certainement dit
c’est vert pour les arbres, l’Amazonie,
la couleur du parti politique.
Mais maintenant, vous le savez,
la couleur de l'environnement,
ce n'est pas vert.
La couleur de l’environnement, c’est bleu,
car sans le bleu,
il n’y aurait pas de vert
et sans le bleu, il n’y aurait pas de vie.
Alors, je vous invite à tous mettre
votre plus beau bleu de travail
pour passer à l’action
et partager avec moi le bonheur
et la satisfaction que l’on a
quand on préserve
ce merveilleux monde marin.
Mais je ne vais pas
vous laisser partir ainsi,
je vais lever le voile
sur ce mystère insoutenable
qui vous tient en haleine depuis le début.
Je vais vous montrer le cabillaud
reconnaissable grâce à son barbillon
pour que vous sachiez maintenant
à quoi ressemble vivant
le poisson de votre assiette.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)